donc on va parler de tout ce qui s'est
passé ce week end à la télé il y a plein
de choses et qui nous a rejoint
c'est dans les roues
[Musique]
en ce moment il y à un héros en france
et il est avec nous alors ne me parlez
pas que sébastien flute café de ddd
résultat formidable tir à l'arc
non mais c'est vrai ne me parlez pas de
teddy riner qui est un des plus grands
sportifs qu'on connaît l'équipe de
france de handball non il y à un héros
aujourd'hui la france lui doit tout l'ue
doit cette sixième place à l'eurovision
où nous étions considérés comme des
moins que rien voilà et tout ça c'est
fini c'est derrière nous grâce à ce gars
a mis ça fait longtemps que ça n'était
pas rêver la meilleure place était
c'était patricia kaas 1/8 dernièrement
voilà tout le dit et amir et expérience
au real
alors aujourd'hui cauet est ce que le
président vous a appelé le président
brésilien
vous avez appelé à encore et j'étais pas
joignable via président françois
hollande
ça m'énerve ce mec là c'est un bond à
venir et toi et les bronzés n'était ou
chez ma famille à tel-aviv
d'accord c'est bien ça s'est bien passé
juif
m
toi qui peux me resserré je préfère on
dirait oui plaisir on a tous six mois
serait pour le faire on a cappella comme
ça qu'on a tous ceux que tu as toujours
la peur de moi
ailleurs servir pour continuer mon vieux
je peux rester comme ça huit ans mais je
vais prendre mon temps alors bon ça
l'eurovision la tnt et était
complètement parce qu'on m'a dit vas-y
la version idéalisée mais là je termine
pas d'horizon terminée mais attends
c'est bon je l' ai écouté pas mal
alors on a fait un petit peu de curling
t jonathan du sport j'ai senti ces
petites gambettes là je peux vous le
dire il n'a pas le dieu vous connais
tous voilà par exemple chez pas mal à
bil'in alabina les bananes à gaza
[Applaudissements]
un mois
la gagne et on gagne à bernard montiel
qui me dit que vous passiez également
sur mfm radio
[Musique]